chief election and campaign
correspondent robert costa joins us now
from washington bob good morning good to
see you
good morning so good to be with you
you've been following these hearings
very very closely what's your takeaway
from the one that we saw yesterday this
was a significant hearing vlad because
we've seen a lot of reporting over the
past year about january 6 but yesterday
for the first time new testimony new
evidence memorialized for history about
how close this country came to having a
president seize voting machines use the
military and we heard from one of his
closest confidants brad parskal about
how this president wanted to bring this
country to the brink of civil war
so bob this is the seventh of these
hearings they're obviously more planned
at this point do you think the committee
is accomplishing what they set out to do
the committee is saying to the country
that they believe the threat of
extremism is a living threat and the
elections ahead in 2022 and 2024 loom so
this is not just a look back to the past
it's a look also ahead to the future
about how extremism white supremacy can
gain a foothold online and in some
corners of the political party the
republican party and this committee is
trying to make a case that the former
president potentially committed a crime
in stirring all of this up ultimately it
will be for the justice department to
decide on that
and there was another bombshell bob at
the end of the hearing congresswoman liz
cheney republican of wyoming said former
president had recently called a witness
that we have not yet heard from what are
you hearing from your sources
if the former president called a witness
and had the intent of tampering that
would be a very serious offense but
still more reporting to be done about
whom exactly the former president
reached out to why he called and what
that was all about we're going to do
more reporting on that in the coming
days and next week's committee hearing
will be a big one prime time on january
6 and trump's conduct
yeah what might be interesting is
according to congresswoman cheney that
person did not take the call is that
right bob that's correct and we are
learning though that the former
president and his allies are keeping an
eye on these proceedings and wondering
who's talking and why
all right bob costa thank you very much
my friend appreciate it